my name is hot Jazz diha I'm part of the
boundaries membership and belonging
program at cfar I think one of the
things that's most exciting about cfar
is that it's really tailor built for
each scholar and the way that they want
to approach their public facing work to
connect with Scholars across disciplines
and really think about research that
might actually improve the future and
not just reflect on the past I'm really
excited about the opportunity to learn
how to speak to policy makers how to
learn how to find The Gatekeepers and
stakeholders that best fit the issues
that I'm most passionate about and cfar
is so well connected that I have no
doubt I will be able to bring these
things to fruition